it's hispanic heritage month from
september 15th
to october 15th and here to celebrate
we're gonna have some friends dropping
by
and share everything that they know and
can like share with us
and my first guest our first guest is
the first latina to create
write produce and star in her own sitcom
please welcome one man band herself
cristela alonso
hey drew what's going on good oh
cristela i love you so much i'm so happy
to be doing this with you
yeah i'm sorry what a coincidence what i
i
i got so excited this morning that i
didn't even mind waking up at like four
in the morning
by the way i know thank you for doing
that and we're gonna do lots of fun
stuff on the show
but thank you for rocking that uh this
morning because i
i i know how it feels um i've woken up
4am my whole life and with my kids and
for this job and it never gets easier
what does hispanic heritage month mean
to you how do you celebrate it
okay so i love my time i always say that
this is my time to shine
so what i like to do is i like to remind
people i'm that person that reminds you
it's hispanic heritage month
i'm not kidding if there is a chance for
me to break out a fun fact
i break it out just to drop some
knowledge i will be
out i could be at a target if somebody's
using something that i know
was usually like invented or like made
popular by someone latino i'm like did
you know blah blah blah like
that is a superpower that i have i just
want that is a perfect segue
all right lay some on me because it's
time for fun facts with cristela alonso
[Applause]
okay i'm gonna tee you up a category and
then you give us all the fun facts that
viewers can keep in our back pocket all
right
what's a fun hispanic heritage month
fact
about food
oh okay okay so you know like when you
go
you know when you go to like an italian
restaurant and you want to be all
authentic and you order a caesar salad
and you're like
eating a salad and it's like oh this is
how italians eat
guess what no caesar salads were
invented
in tijuana mexico i have to say it in
spanish because
tijuana not italy it was tijuana
so next time you order an italian you
know like you're at an italian
restaurant and you order a caesar salad
you can order a cesar salad because
that's actually a little bit more
appropriate
oh my god my mind is blown i did not
know that
okay wait okay news newsy fun fact
oh uh oh there's so many to pick from
uh okay okay so
um 2020 it's been quite a year and one
of our favorite go-to's is
hand sanitizer and hand sanitizer was
actually invented by a nurse
named lupe hernandez in like the 60s i
want to say it's like 1966 or something
she wanted to be able to sterilize to be
like would sterilize her hands
without using soap and water and just in
case and she created an alcohol gel
which now in 2020 we just always
use everything that is so cool
okay no no right oh my god no i want to
like offline about all of this okay a
pop culture fun fact
uh pop culture this is a
this is a good one uh not really
invented but i do give her credit
uh so google images all right so let's
say that i have a celebrity crush
because i have like three
and i want to look at what they look
like recently i go to google images and
i'm like oh my god they look like this
google images actually was created
after jennifer lopez wore her very
popular versace green dress
really yes because people after after
she wore it
to the grammys everybody wanted to see
what it looked like
so they started doing a search on google
and they would just like go
in and then google said you know people
are really looking up at
about like jlo with this green dress you
know so oh i love that
because i love lopez i well she just is
such a trendsetter
and thank her because i live for google
image okay entrepreneur fun fact
oh uh let's see uh the
the beauty blender which i actually use
for makeup right now
the beauty blender that was actually
invented by a latina makeup artist
i want to say her name was rhian silva
and she was actually the makeup artist
she did it on the set of girlfriends
which
has a theme song that i like to rock to
but yeah she
created the beauty blender that really
kind of mixes our foundations in a
really awesome way
and you know what cristela i have a fun
fact to add to that which is
that she got a mock-up
from the lab of the beauty blender and
it wasn't supposed to be in that pink
color
they were like ignore the color which
you hear all the time when you're
looking at beauty and lab samples
um they're like ignore the packaging
ignore this so they were like ignore the
color and she saw and she was like no
this is the color and look what happened
i mean she changed everything
did you fun fact my fun fact i might
have
i might have doubled down on you
cristela absolutely on your fun facts
now
actually i also have one last fun fact
which is cristela alonso is the first
latina to be a pixar lead
in cars 3 as cruz ramirez and that is a
fun fact
and we have so much more fun things to
do with priscella i love you
thank you for being here
you